[Music]
well
we all know that social media
they often have giveaways right like a
lot of influencers they do giveaways
but have you ever heard of a sperm
donor giveaway what who want my [ __ ]
so like if you're like a nba basketball
player and you're like i know everyone
wants my sperm so
um who wants to do this new challenge
tag your friend
make sure to i'll choose one person to
send my sperm to
that i think is way weirder than this
but
that's actually like what the heck
korean abdul jabbar actually did that
for a couple years
why but he would just direct deposit
stupid
did he really yeah yeah really thousands
thousands of people thousands
magic johnson he's known for it magic
johnson i don't believe you
he said he said in his book that he
[ __ ] ten thousand chicks or something
ten 000. they need to do a [ __ ]
espn on him right 30 for 30.
hell yeah ten thousand for ten thousand
thirty for thirty did they call it ten
thousand
that'd be sick wow that's a lot of
people
now so this story here it's around these
two the same sex couple instagram
influencers how they gonna give out come
so their name is ali and sam
and they posted this donor sperm
giveaway because they partnered up with
a sperm bank and they
announced this donor sperm giveaway and
then people took this
went to twitter and were like what the
[ __ ] like
instagram instagram's going to be hey we
think he got hacked
that's the first thing i think right
yeah cause i'm still confused
like are they both gonna carry or one is
gonna carry okay so the situation here
is that they are
because of the fact that they partnered
up with this bank they
wanted to give an opportunity to one of
their followers that are trying to
conceive
um the opportunity for some free
donors is it super expensive to get a
donor
yeah so it turns out that it can cost
somewhere between
where is it six hundred and fifty
dollars to a thousand
fifty that's some premium calm dude
we're way cheaper than chicks though
yeah because that shit's like eggs is
nuts it's thousands
like thousands and then the in vitro or
whatever that shit's even
more too and then the carrying and all
that like damn girls are more valuable
damn because i bet you like that 650
dollars
it's like from a nobel peace prize
winning like
top-notch [ __ ] and i'm like your
comes only worth that much
dude you speak for like thirty thousand
dude he probably got only got paid like
20 bucks imagine a nobel peace
prize winner though beating off in the
bathroom so he can give you
hell yeah he's like you guys got any
more mags i need some more [ __ ] up
[ __ ] than this this isn't doing it for
me it doesn't work for me
this isn't any good remember that china
machine that
extracts the come out it looks like a
sucking machine
yeah you walk up to it it's like this
white apron thing looking
it's crazy you just like stand in front
of it yeah and it goes
like that and i was like damn i want to
see if that machine actually is good
i want to see if it's actually a machine
or for somebody on the other side oh my
god
like a [ __ ] like what i did when i
was a kid when i put
uh a roll uh a robot shell on top of a
toy car and i'm like i have a robot
like nah you didn't make a robot dude so
you got a chinese guy in there just
sucking all day beating people off all
day
it sounds like he's good at it
to get paid and to know that you could
do it in a certain time would you guys
be down
oh [ __ ] let's say there is a like i mean
we're all heterosexual here so we
obviously prefer chicks but let's say uh
we go on first
we've got another company trip to vegas
and then there's this show where it's
like
the world's best masturbator down
i would have to and it's a dude world's
best master he's the best jacker offer
in the world
oh would you guys have to just try it to
see if this guy is really that good
well i don't know because sometimes
people say like they're the world's best
sandwich
and there's no committee so that just
means i'm going to get jacked off by a
dude that claims he's the best
this guy's certified if he's certified
by the committee oh
by the way the nobel committee the nobel
peace
if he's won a nobel peace prize for the
u.n he's a u.n certified
yo i jacked off dictators and i stopped
wars
yeah then i'd have to try that
you know why because it's not even about
like anything
sexual at that point at that point it's
like i gotta see what the [ __ ] is
happening here like this guy's the
guinness record for being the best hand
driver
it'll be extremely difficult if i'm limp
the whole time
so i'm like how you gonna get me hard
especially if he looks like asthma
because i want to do that would i would
you let me do it if it's a guy jacking
you up yeah
oh god i have to film it what if it's a
girl
what if it's a girl that is also the
world's best um
she said she's the best at jacqueline i
don't know if i'd film it but what i
would comment
because i'd have to challenge her now
and i'm like no
why are you being why are you being
sexist what
why are you being sexy she's being so
sexist yeah because my eyes can do it
i'm scared that she's gonna be better
than me and then he's not going to want
me anymore oh i thought you were
thinking that girls can't do hand jobs
as good as guys can
just kitty and they can and they can by
the way
well thanks steve i don't even like hand
jobs anymore that's just a blast from
the past
what the [ __ ] is high school for you
yeah you got to graduate
okay where are you at now since you're
so advanced [ __ ] rim jobs i think we
know yeah rim jobs is your fourth place
i thought that was like 2016.
it's still pretty top-notch to me it's
top of the chart still
yeah it withstood the test of time it's
not the it's it's greatest hits
i don't know how to expand on it yet
that's what i'm saying i'm going inside
what do you mean i tried anal no on you
on yourself
you know you've tried you've accepted
ana
i'm not there yet
hello they call me little peg boy
my my name is pegboard okay oh pegboard
that's it
no uh i don't think i'm there yet maybe
maybe when i'm
give me 10 more years i mean it's been
four years 2016. i know but then like
i haven't [ __ ] that much it's time
when something goes inside of you
get less exciting you're like pick it up
yeah time to pick it up
hit me in the [ __ ] man spot whatever
it's called the prostate yeah the
prostate gland man
check me check if i have cancer girl you
know what i mean
would you hold your own ass at that
point whatever
whatever works too oh wait do you hold
your own ass when you're getting a rim
no what you can't answer like that
because he's gripping the sheets yes
i'm too busy i'm too busy holding the
nightstand dude
what you're standing up no
that would be funny next you handcuffed
with a ball gagging dude that might be
give me a couple years give me a couple
of years i don't know
i haven't really ventured through all of
it yet so i i don't know i haven't
gotten
electrical wires on my nipples and got
zapped
whatever you know like i haven't done
all the nipple clamps have you done that
plants clamps oh no i don't i don't know
i never
i never got into like bondage and all
that stuff so
yeah maybe feathers i'll [ __ ] with
feathers
i haven't [ __ ] with that tickle tickle
me i don't know it's
kind of cute that is cute i feel like
it's kind of down from where you're at
right now though
it is i think i think i think i went i
went kind of hardcore
and then now i just want to go a little
softer you know we got to balance it out
right like you can't
you can't lift weights all day you got a
paddleboard you know
you went paddle boarding recently that's
what i'm saying i gotta use those
analogies you know you gotta
you gotta do something soft and fun and
you gotta do some parkour [ __ ]
if bart wanted you to rim him would you
yeah rim's just licking right
yeah i got so scared because even though
you were looking that way for some
reason my
brain processed it as as him doing it
and i was like wait what's happening
what about him
i don't want to that's my follow-up
that's my follow-up question [ __ ]
invite me into this that was my
follow-up question my brain is
going to be the world's best rimmer in
las vegas i
see in las vegas yeah what if this
world's best rimmer is like in
bakersfield nah cause i'm not even gonna
be there in the first place
set the mood for me i can't be like yo i
got the world's best hand job in
bakersfield they're like oh
but if i was like i was in las vegas had
to try this thing
the best of the best go with everyone
it's like i was in the mood
las vegas has this weird feeling of like
sexual deviancy
you know [ __ ] it let's do whatever yeah
it doesn't it's not the best though
like if you're like i got a hand job in
venice who's the best ever
oh [ __ ] like like venice italy but
that's too classy
mm-hmm oh i see that needs to be kind of
dirty it needs to be it like
the the branding needs to be like it's
it's like sex town
yeah but i don't want to be like oh i
want a parisian hand job what about
amsterdam
maybe amsterdamian i think it is yeah i
got you
i take it back i don't want a man to
jack me off okay
i started imagining like a real man and
i got scared
but he's got really soft hands soft
little well
jason chen hands can we put abe's hands
because his hands are soft he's a soft
little
bag what if he don't even see him he
puts his hand through gloves and a table
no gloves i like real skin real skin you
have to touch my friend
abe's hand oh okay every time you shake
his hand
you go i want to feel that on my dick
what yeah it's that good wow have you
let abe know this
these are yours i think you just i did i
told him i was like dude
you must have a blast jacking off
because your [ __ ] hands are amazing
and i'm like how do you even get it like
that even after you play basketball
oh cause he's really good he has really
soft hands i thought he just went from i
don't want a guy to jack me off too
i would i want abe's hands oh i know who
i wanted
a friend of mine not my penis hey i i
have the ability to separate
the person from the body part okay i
have then why would you not do it with
bart
there we go so you don't have the
ability what if he's the world's best
jacker officer his hands are rough
not anymore he moisturizes every single
night i know what his hands feel like
go touch him they're different now i
promise you i don't need to know because
not like abe's hands
abe is like he's afraid he's going to
like it that's why he doesn't want to
touch him that's not forbidden love
is because he has his hands aren't that
different from mine
and if i can go like this and it's the
same hands nelson got similar hands
i'm just it's not a big [ __ ] deal
okay
but if you have something completely
different like a gecko's hand
and i'm like what is that this is alien
i have to say i not to brag to her but i
do have pretty soft hands you have nice
hands
this whole time are you known for it
because i'm like he hasn't oh my god
have you felt his hand
it's too big but but what about michael
it's pre-lubed okay
michael's hands are always pre-loaded
it's blue but it's not soft hands are
softer than mine
yeah are they yeah you have the softest
hands ever
don't ever touch me again it's soft
because
too that's why it's too big it's really
moisturizing i'm sorry steve
i don't want the abominable snowman
jacking me off i want
i want i want soft lady fingers these
are good hands he's got lady fingers
they're just big
i have big hands too if i was a foot
bigger if i was yao ming size
and then your hands would fit my dick
i would be okay with it but at this time
it might crush your dick
yeah it's too it's too scary it's too
[ __ ] scary
he's like two fingers that's all you
need no it's like i don't want a grizzly
bear jacking me off okay
that's how i get around a big [ __ ] too
so i get it i've been afraid
right it's not it's it's it's
intimidating dude
abe if you're out there
[Music]
you